Most moms are pretty great, so great in fact
that in the early 20th century a woman called
Anna Jarvis campaigned tirelessly to recognise
them on a national scale- a decision Jarvis
would later come to regret culminating in
her more or less dedicating her life and life’s
savings to destroy the Frankenstein’s monster
of a holiday the greeting card industry molded
her creation into.
First celebrated on May 10, 1908, the first
official Mother’s Day was a somewhat sombre
affair marked by a touching speech given by
the aforementioned Anna Jarvis in memory of
her late mother, social activist Ann Maria
Reeves Jarvis, who’d passed away some 3
years earlier.
The approximately 70 minute speech, which
was delivered in the auditorium of the Wanamaker’s
department store in Philadelphia to a reported
crowd of about 5,000 people, was by all accounts
profoundly moving and resonated deeply with
the audience in attendance.
Around the same time, Jarvis paid to have
500 white carnations sent to the Andrews Methodist
Episcopal Church in Grafton, West Virginia,
where she once taught Sunday School, with
attendees encouraged to wear these as a small
token of their gratitude for all their own
mothers had done for them.
While this was by no means the first attempt
Jarvis had made to celebrate mothers as a
concept, it was the first that had a big ol’
stack of cash behind it, with noted Philadelphia
businessman and former U.S. Postmaster General
John Wanamaker (who owned the store Jarvis
gave the aforementioned speech at) backing
Jarvis financially and politically.
Spurred by the success of the event, Jarvis
began a letter writing campaign to have Mother’s
Day officially recognised as a national holiday.
After six years, she got here wish, with Mother’s
Day being acknowledged by no less of an authority
than the President of the United States himself,
Woodrow Wilson.
On May 9, 1914, he issued a presidential proclamation
that read that this is the day we “[publicly
express] our love and reverence for the mothers
of our country.”
The thing is, as soon as Mother’s Day became
officially recognised as a national holiday,
the greeting card and floral industry began
circling it like hungry sharks that had smelled
the unmistakable whiff of a seal basting itself
in BBQ sauce.
Jarvis responded by denouncing any commercialization
of Mother’s Day, thinking any attempt to
make money off of Mother’s Day – even
if it was for a good cause – was wrong and
not in the spirit of the thing.
After all, something like a hand written note
expressing your personal feelings is far superior,
in her opinion, than some store bought card.
As she said,
A printed card means nothing except that you
are too lazy to write to the woman who has
done more for you than anyone in the world.
And candy!
You take a box to Mother—and then eat most
of it yourself.
A pretty sentiment.
She went on in a 1924 interview with the Miami
Daily News,
The white carnation is the emblem of Mother’s
Day because it typifies the beauty, truth
and fidelity of mother-love.
This emblem is used on the Mother’s Day
association printed matter and official buttons.
But it does not mean that people should wear
a white carnation.
This false idea has led to florists flagrantly
boosting the price of white carnations for
the Mother’s Day trade.
The red carnation has no connection with Mother’s
Day.
Yet florists have spread the idea that it
should be worn for mother who has passed away.
This has boosted the sale of red carnations.
Confectioners put a white ribbon on a box
of candy and advance the price just because
it’s Mother’s Day.
There is no connection between candy and this
day.
It is pure commercialization.
Thus, offended by the amorphous blob of empty
saccharine sentiments her creation had been
morphed into, Jarvis spent the rest of her
life trying to destroy Mother’s Day, among
other things filing countless lawsuits against
various entities related to the holiday, including
one against a non-profit Mother’s Day organization
headed up by none other than First Lady Eleanor
Roosevelt.
Although, it should be noted that while Jarvis
hated the commercialization of Mother’s
Day, in fact, it is very possible that had
it not been commercialized it would have been
largely relegated to a minor holiday, or disappeared
altogether, as has happened to numerous other
such holidays over the centuries.
As you look at the history of holidays, the
ones that survive and become extremely popular
are nearly always the ones that get commercialized
in some way.
If there’s money to be made on a certain
holiday, businesses will literally advertise
the holiday, making sure that it is as popular
as it can be and that it sticks around.
Of course, this would have been little consolation
to Jarvis, who would rather have seen Mother’s
Day die completely than see the commercialized
version survive, with Jarvis lamenting “that
she was sorry she had ever started Mother’s
Day.”
In the end, Jarvis was unable to stop Mother’s
Day from becoming something she didn’t want.
She subsequently went into reclusion in the
final years of her life.
In debt, angry and in failing health, she
lived for a time in a giant brick mansion
in Philadelphia with her blind sister, Lillian.
Outside the mansion was a sign alerting visitors
“Warning — Stay Away.”
Eventually her health declined to the point
where she herself went blind and she needed
outside care, at which point she was put into
the Marshall Square Sanitarium in Pennsylvania.
As she didn’t have any money to pay for
the care she was receiving there, ironically,
the bill was reportedly largely paid for by
a group of businessmen in the floral industry
that so benefited from her great idea.
Naturally so as to avoid upsetting the elderly
Jarvis, it appears she was never told of their
part in paying for her care.
Jarvis ultimately lived to the ripe old age
of 84, dying penniless and, as she never married
nor had children, more or less alone in the
sanitarium…
If you’ve ever wondered why it is “Mother’s
Day” and not “Mothers’ Day”, that
is largely thanks to Jarvis who stated it
should “be a singular possessive, for each
family to honour their mother, not a plural
possessive commemorating all mothers
in the world.”